well if me I would try to cool it on
some of this heated rhetoric I really
like what secretary mattis did about I
don't know half a dozen missile tests
ago when he simply said we note that
North Koreans have launched a missile
and we have no further comment that
would drive the North Koreans crazy
because the you know this place -
they're craving for attention for face
and so Kim Yuna's has got to be eating
this up when the president United States
is engaging directly with him and in the
manner in which he's he's doing it and
of course they use this for again for
domestic consumption in North Korea and
at a point I'd make in terms of these
threats about our readiness to you know
in convey conduct military hostile
military action well I think one thing I
hope they're thinking about what about
the military dependents the families of
our military people and the civilians
that who are there and in State
Department Department of Defense not to
mention the thousands of Americans who
live in the Republic of Korea not to
mention the tens of thousands of dual
citizens so if we're going to if we're
serious about initiating hostile
military action North Korea I certainly
hope there's some thought given to the
fate of these people